MINE.
>> THAT SAME ANSWER AS 6:00 THIS
MORNING.
KARA SCANNELL, THANK YOU FOR ALL
YOUR HARD WORK ALL DAY LONG.
>>> STAYING ON THE THEME, JUST
IN ON WHAT HAPPENED SHORTLY
AFTER THE MAR-A-LAGO SEARCH,
FORMER WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF MARK MEADOWS BEGAN TURNING
OVER ITEMS TO THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES.
THIS IS DIFFERENT, RIGHT?
SO LET'S GET THE REPORTING ON
THIS FROM CNN'S KRISTEN HOLMES.
WHAT HAVE YOU LEARNED?
>> THESE ARE BRAND NEW DETAILS
THAT SHOW THE LEVEL OF
INTERACTION BETWEEN MEADOWS AND
THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES AS WELL AS
WHAT EXACTLY HE SUBMITTED.
SOURCES TELL OUR COLLEAGUES THAT
WITHIN A WEEK OF THAT SEARCH AT
MAR-A-LAGO, MEADOWS SUBMITTED
TEXT MESSAGES AND EMAILS TO THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES.
IT WAS LESS THAN A DOZEN EMAILS.
NOW, THIS WAS ACTUALLY PART OF
AN EARLIER REQUEST FOR ALL
ELECTRONIC CORRESPONDENCE THAT
FALLS UNDER THE PRESIDENTIAL
RECORDS ACT.
WHAT'S INTERESTING HERE IS THE
ARCHIVES REALIZED THAT IT HADN'T
GOTTEN EVERYTHING FROM MEADOWS
WHEN IT SAW WHAT MEADOWS HAD
ACTUALLY TURNED OVER TO THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE.
THAT'S WHEN THEY STARTED PUTTING
IN THAT EARLIER REQUEST.
ONE THING TO PAY ATTENTION HERE
IS THAT MEADOWS HAS ACTUALLY
BEEN WORKING WITH THE ARCHIVES
ON A DIFFERENT LEVEL AS WELL.
THAT'S SOMETHING WE LEARNED
THROUGH THIS REPORTING.
FOR ABOUT A YEAR, BECAUSE HE IS
ONE OF TRUMP'S DESIGNEES TO THE
ARCHIVES.
SO HE WAS CALLED BY ANOTHER
DESIGNEE LAST SUMMER, A YEAR
AGO, TO TRY TO HELP GET TRUMP TO
GIVE THESE RECORDS BACK TO THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES.
SO KIND OF A WEIRD POSITION FOR
HIM TO BE IN, TURNING IT OVER
AND THEN ALSO HE WAS TRYING TO
HELP WITH THE TRUMP ANGLE OF
THIS.
>> AND THE TIMING OF THIS.
IS THIS A COINCIDENCE?
WHAT DO YOU KNOW ABOUT THAT?
>> WELL, THAT'S OBVIOUSLY THE
BIG QUESTION HERE.
NOW, WE HAVE ONE SOURCE FAMILIAR
WITH THE MATTER WHO SAYS THAT
THIS IS TOTALLY A COINCIDENCE,
THAT THE SEARCH HAD NOTHING TO
DO WITH MEADOWS' DECISION TO
TURN OVER THESE CORRESPONDENCE.
BUT ANOTHER SOURCE, WHO IS ALSO
FAMILIAR, SAID IT COULD BE A
COINCIDENCE BUT WE DID GET FAR
MORE AFTER THE SEARCH THAN WE
HAD EVER GOTTEN BEFORE WITH THIS
REQUEST.
>> ALL RIGHT.
INTERESTING.
I'M SURE THERE WILL BE MORE
REPORTING FROM YOU AND YOUR TEAM
ON THIS VERY SUBJECT.
KRISTEN HOLMES, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
>>> PERSPECTIVE NOW FROM SENIOR
ANALYST ELIE HONIG.
ALSO CNN LEGAL AND NATIONAL
SECURITY ANALYST CARRIE CORDERO,
A FORMER COUNSEL TO THE
ASSISTANT ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
CARRIE, FIRST, JUST YOUR
REACTION TO KRISTEN'S REPORTING
ON MARK MEADOWS' CORRESPONDENCE
WITH THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES.
DOES THAT RAISE ANY RED FLAGS TO
YOU?
>> WELL, IT IS -- THE TIMING IS
INTERESTING.
YOU KNOW, IT'S HARD TO DRAW TOO
MANY CONCLUSIONS FROM IT.
BUT THE FACT THAT A PHYSICAL
SEARCH WAS EXECUTED, THAT A
WARRANT WAS ISSUED FROM THE
JUDGE TO BE ABLE TO SEARCH THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S RESIDENCE
WITH RESPECT TO DOCUMENTS THAT
NEEDED TO BE RETURNED TO THE
ARCHIVES MOST LIKELY I WOULD
THINK GOT THE ATTENTION OF MARK
MEADOWS AND HIS LAWYERS.
SO EVEN IF THEY WERE IN A
PROCESS ALREADY ENGAGING WITH
THE ARCHIVES, I WOULDN'T BE
SURPRISED IF WE LEARNED DOWN THE
ROAD THAT THAT SPED UP THEIR
COMPLIANCE WITH THE ARCHIVES'
REQUEST.
>> ELIE, BACK TO THE SEARCH AT
MAR-A-LAGO SPECIFICALLY, YOU
LOOK AT EVERYTHING THE FBI
RECOVERED, NOT ONLY THE TOP
SECRET DOCUMENTS BUT THE MORE
THAN 11,000 NON-CLASSIFIED
GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS.
AS A PROSECUTOR, WHAT CAN YOU
CONCLUDE FROM THIS?
WHERE DOES IT LEAD YOU?
>> JOHN, IT RAISES A LOT OF
QUESTIONS FOR ME.
MY ATTENTION IS DRAWN
IMMEDIATELY TO THOSE EMPTY FILE
FOLDERS FOR CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION THAT YOU WERE JUST
DISCUSSING WITH KARA.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
QUESTIONS YOU SET OUT TO ANSWER.
FIRST OF ALL, DID THEY EVER
CONTAIN DOCUMENTS OR DID THEY
EVER CONTAIN DOCUMENTS WHILE AT
MAR-A-LAGO?
NOT NECESSARILY, BUT PERHAPS
SOME OF THEM DID.
SO WHAT DOCUMENTS?
WHERE WERE THEY?
WERE THEY RECOVERED WHERE ELSE
AT MAR-A-LAGO OR ARE THEY GONE?
THAT WOULD BE OF COURSE THE MOST
CONCERNING OUTCOME.
AND THEN FINALLY, IF YOU CAN
ASCERTAIN, IF YOU'RE THINKING
ABOUT CHARGING SOMEBODY, YOU
NEED TO KNOW WHO HANDLED THEM,
WHO MISHANDLED THEM, WHAT THEY
DID WITH THEM AND CAN YOU SHOW
THE RELEVANT INTENT AND
KNOWLEDGE.
FOR THAT YOU'D HAVE TO TALK TO
YOUR WITNESSES, PROBABLY WANT TO
LOOK AT THAT SURVEILLANCE TAPE
THAT DOJ SUBPOENAED.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO SEND SOME OF
THE DOCUMENTS FOR FINGERPRINTING
OR DNA.
SO I THINK THERE'S A WHOLE BUNCH
MORE QUESTIONS RAISED BY THE NEW
FILING.
>> THAT'S JUST THE EMPTY FOLDERS
THERE.
CARRIE, YOU LOOK AT ALL THE
PAPERWORK, THERE'S SO MUCH
MATERIAL THERE.
THERE'S JUST A LOT OF MATERIAL.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF MATERIAL,
IT'S A LOT OF DOCUMENTS.
AND REMEMBER, THESE DOCUMENTS
BELONG TO THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT.
AND THAT'S REALLY THE BASIC
PREMISE THAT IS UNDERLYING ALL
OF THIS.
I DO THINK THAT THE FACT THAT SO
MUCH OF THIS INFORMATION WAS
CLASSIFIED, INCLUDING LOTS OF
INFORMATION AT TOP SECRET
LEVELS, COMPARTMENTED PROGRAMS,
REALLY HIGHLY CLASSIFIED
PROGRAMS, THAT WOULD HAVE LIT
THE FIRE UNDER THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TO SAY WE CAN'T WAIT
ANYMORE.
WE'VE BEEN ENGAGED IN A DIALOGUE
FOR AS LONG AS WE COULD.
WE NEED TO GET THESE DOCUMENTS
BACK AND DO THE DAMAGE
ASSESSMENT LED BY THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY TO FIGURE
OUT WHERE THIS INFORMATION MAY
HAVE BEEN VIEWED, GONE, BEEN
SEEN BY, OR NOT.
YOU KNOW, THAT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT TOO, FOR THEM TO
DETERMINE, YOU KNOW WHAT, THESE
DOCUMENTS JUST SAT IN THE
OFFICES AND BASEMENTS OR
LOCATIONS WITHIN MAR-A-LAGO AND
DIDN'T GET OUT.
THAT WOULD BE IMPORTANT TO KNOW
AS WELL.
BUT AT SOME POINT I THINK THE
CLASSIFICATION LEVEL OF THE
DOCUMENTS AND THE VOLUME OF
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION IS WHAT
IS DRIVING THE INTENSITY OF THIS
INVESTIGATION, WHICH CLEARLY IS
ONGOING.
>> ELIE, THE FORMER ATTORNEY
GENERAL, BILL BARR, SAID THEY
JAWBONED FOR MORE THAN A YEAR
OVER THIS BEFORE THEY ULTIMATELY
ISSUED THE SEARCH WARRANT THERE.
I WANT TO PLAY A LITTLE BIT MORE
OF WHAT HE SAID ON FOX NEWS.
>> I FRANKLY AM SKEPTICAL OF
THIS CLAIM THAT I DECLASSIFIED
EVERYTHING.
BECAUSE FRANKLY, I THINK IT'S
HIGHLY IMPROBABLE AND, SECOND,
IF IN FACT HE SORT OF STOOD OVER
SCORES OF BOXES, NOT REALLY
KNOWING WHAT WAS IN THEM AND
SAID I HERE BY DECLASSIFY
EVERYTHING IN HERE, THAT WOULD
BE SUCH AN ABUSE THAT -- AND
SHOW SUCH RECKLESSNESS THAT IT'S
ALMOST WORSE THAN TAKING THE
DOCUMENTS.
>> ELIE, YOU LITERALLY WROTE THE
BOOK ON THIS GUY.
YOU WROTE A BOOK ON THE FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL WILLIAM BARR.
DOES WHAT HE SAID SURPRISE YOU?
>> WELL, I'M GOING TO SAY
SOMETHING I RARELY SAY.
I AGREE WITH BILL BARR ON THIS.
I THINK HE HIT THE NAIL ON THE
HEAD ON THIS.
BILL BARR IS THE ULTIMATE
UNITARY EXECUTIVE GUY.
IN HIS VIEW THE PRESIDENT HAS
THE ULTIMATE POWER IN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
I'M SURE HE IS OF THE VIEW THE
PRESIDENT HAS UNLIMITED POWER TO
DECLASSIFY.
BUT HE'S SAYING EVEN IF THE
PRESIDENT HAS UNLIMITED POWER TO
DECLASSIFY, THERE IS NO EVIDENCE
AND PLENTY OF COUNTEREVIDENCE TO
THIS NOTION THAT HE ACTUALLY DID
IT.
YOU CAN HAVE THE POWER BUT IF
YOU DIDN'T EXERCISE IT WHEN YOU
WERE PRESIDENT, YOU CAN'T
EXERCISE IT NOW IN 2022.
I AGREE WITH BILL BARR ON THAT
AND I AGREE WITH HIM ON THE
EARLIER CLIP THAT WE PLAYED.
HE CAN UNDERSTAND AS A FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL THAT BASICALLY
DOJ GOT STRUNG ALONG OVER A
YEAR, JAWBONED TO USE HIS
COLORFUL EXPRESSION.
I THINK HE'S RIGHT WHEN HE
CONCLUDES THAT DOJ HAD NO CHOICE
BUT TO GO IN AND EXECUTE THAT
SEARCH WARRANT.
>> ONE OTHER THING HE SAID, BILL
BARR, THE WHOLE IDEA OF A
SPECIAL MASTER IS A RED HERRING
AND A WASTE OF TIME.
PART OF HIS REASONING IS THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAS ALREADY
GONE THROUGH THE DOCUMENTS.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> HE UNDERSTANDS THE WAY
INVESTIGATIONS WORK AND THE FACT
THAT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT HAD
A TEAM TO REVIEW ANY POSSIBLE
ATTORNEY/CLIENT INFORMATION,
WHICH REALLY THERE WAS NOTHING
ABOUT THIS SEARCH THAT WOULD
HAVE RAISED THE LEVEL OF
POTENTIAL ATTORNEY/CLIENT
INFORMATION.
SO YES, HE'S RIGHT.
A SPECIAL MASTER AT THIS POINT
IS NOT NEEDED IN MY JUDGMENT.
IT SEEMS LIKE IN HIS JUDGMENT AS
WELL.
REALLY THE LONGER THAT THE JUDGE
GOES ON TO CONSIDER IT, THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT JUST REVIEWS
MORE AND MORE INFORMATION.
AT THIS POINT THEY HAVE EVEN
SAID IN THEIR PLEADINGS THAT
THEY HAVE COMPLETED, COMPLETED
THEIR PRELIMINARY REVIEW.
ONE OTHER POINT REAL QUICK,
JOHN, ON THE POINT THAT FORMER
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR WAS MAKING
ON THE DECLASSIFICATION.
WHEN DOCUMENTS WERE
DECLASSIFIED, THEY ACTUALLY
CHANGE IN THEIR APPEARANCE.
LINES ARE DRAWN THROUGH THE
CLASSIFICATION MARKINGS.
I THINK WHAT IS SHOWN SO FAR
THROUGH THE PHOTOGRAPH AND OTHER
INFORMATION IS THAT THERE IS
LITERALLY